bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors un article 24 et
réécrit remplacer pourquoi ces deux mois
de calmer la colère des manifestants
alors si loin de calmer la colère des
manifestants parce que cette loi qui
vise à mieux protéger nos forces de
l'ordre ont fait l anb est une partie de
la gauche pour qui c'est insupportable
de défendre davantage les policiers on
se devait de toute façon la police et
les forces de l'ordre ne sont peu ou pas
mais ne peuvent pas être victimes comme
on le voit dans la réalité de guet-apens
des prises à partie et d'escampette
maintenant les cibles d'une nouvelle
délinquance
elle est d'une guerre pour le contrôle
du territoire
c'est ce qui dérange sur la réécriture
de l'article 24
il ya un point d'interrogation notamment
sur les libertés de la presse le sénat
le lait c'est un progrès seront
justement de son référence au code civil
pour nous peut impliquer la question de
la liberté donc justement l'année les
points d'inquiétude qui était sauvée au
début du mouvement une soupe illégitime
selon vous les points négatifs on était
à soulever ils ont été soulevées par le
sénat comme ça un travail plus
approfondi la colère sommet national
notamment en mobilisant à un avis de la
cnil sur la question des drogues est un
point très sensible
la cnil oran rhin à vic c'est
intéressant d'avoir notamment une zone
une période d'évaluation et surtout de
mieux limité et de définir un cadre
beaucoup plus précis l'utilisation des
drones et des images aériennes chose qui
n'avait pas été fait auparavant et qui
n'est pas été définies dans le projet de
loi initial
parce que la cnil l'a dit l'encadrement
juridique est insuffisant notamment par
rapport à l'utilisation des drones donc
cet encadrement juridique voulzy tu as
été revu par les sénateurs le sénat a
fait un travail de fond justement pour
lever toutes ces ambiguïtés et les
insuffisances du texte en termes de
liberté en termes de doutes concernant
la liberté de la presse sur la question
au moins de recueillir l'avis de
in sur une question aussi sensible des
données et l'utilisation des drones ça
devait en fait le minimum il n'avait pas
été fait auparavant utilisé peut-être au
début mais de quel constat est parti le
gouvernement pour finalement se dire que
cette loi est aujourd'hui un besoin une
nécessité en france ces formes d'art qui
est complètement on est dans une
situation où on a plus de délinquance
plus d'insécurité des forces de vente
qui sont prises à partie et la solution
pour une partie de la gauche et dire
qu'il faut moins de forces de l'ordre
alors que sur tous les problèmes et dans
tous les autres domaines
il appelle à toujours plus de moyens dès
qu'il ya un souci donc la réalité celle
qu'on a un phénomène d'insécurité de
contrôle du territoire dans certains
quartiers des rivalités entre des bandes
ailleurs et finalement la réponse ça ne
peut pas être moins de force de l'autre
doit être davantage de forces de l'ordre
avec davantage de moyens et surtout un
cadre législatif qui permettent de les
protéger
puisque en 2018 elle est plus de 10000
forces de l'ordre ont été blessés dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions donc il
faut davantage de moyens et mieux
protéger nos forces de l'ordre pour
rétablir le calme et la paix dans notre
pays aujourd'hui en france est-ce qu'il
faut protéger les forces de l'ordre bien
sûr qu'il faut les protéger
pas si vous avez dû voir ces scènes sur
les réseaux sociaux ou des forces de
l'ordre qui a parti on entend des tués
les tuer les dons qui sont véritablement
pris pour cible et c'est pas uniquement
on pourrait dire que c'est uniquement la
question des policiers parce qu'ils
représentent leur nom la question c'est
c'est tous les représentants de la
république et de l'état qu'elles sont
possibles lorsque les policiers pour
qu'ils vont dans ces quartiers elles
viennent pas pour taper faire des
contrôles ou donner des amendes pour
sauver des vies et on le fait que des
médecins des policiers des maires soient
pris pour cible ce n'est pas une
question de la police c'est une question
de contrôle du territoire il ya une
lutte notamment à travers le trafic de
drogue pour garder le contrôle des
quartiers et garder une main mise sur un
trafic et sur des des sources de revenus
qui sont indispensables pour ces
délinquants
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur arte france